I think what's really exciting about the
work that we do in in hyper studio is to
explore the possibility the potential of
digital media for learning and research
in the humanities and Social Sciences
digital humanities is not only an
emergent it's an exploding field and in
terms of the future trajectory of
digital humanities there's clearly an
aspect of working with very large
datasets this is something that's very
popular right now and we need to
understand what are the right tools to
do that the hyper studio answers a
really profound question we've digitized
amazing amounts of newspapers books
films video sound now what what do we do
with this digitized material and the
hyper studio is all about both
developing tools and with those tools
developing new ways to think about those
datasets basically they're allowing us
to push the questions that have driven
the humanities since you know for the
last thousand plus years they're
allowing us to take those questions and
push them in whole new directions so the
hyper study has developed a number of
tools especially tools that allow very
interesting data visualizations
one is for example a time line and time
lines have been used for centuries and
they are very interesting time lines and
when you look around on the web what's
available there are very standard time
lines and it's always the linear time
line but we see those tools as enabling
tools to represent the data and to
constantly modify the way you can
visualize and represent the data one
project that we're working on is the
us-iran project it's a diplomatic
history project about the missed
opportunities between the two countries
and there are perspectives for example
there are timelines and dates that are
relevant for the Iranian side but there
are dates that are relevant for this
process from the US side and if you can
just oppose these you can immediately
detect for example where are the gaps
because states that are important for
the Iranians might not be important for
the American side so you around these
moments in a data set you can discover
moments that are relevant for further
research for example we have a project
with the history department here at MIT
Jeff Ravel who is a theater historian
and this is a project that we're doing
in collaboration with the comedie
francaise
in in Paris by representing the
performance States along a visual line
here one can immediately detect two gaps
in the performance dates so one
immediately asks the question what
happened here why is there such a large
gap well it turns out by pulling in
other kinds of information it was
actually the death of the French King
Louis the 15th
visualizing that in really interesting
ways over time allows the scholars to
students to gain very interesting new
insights in the humanities we have to be
the ones who influence of the technical
development because we want the tools
that are helpful for us we want specific
humanities tools that work in additional
environment so that we can actually do
the research and the teaching and the
learning that we want to do and that are
necessary for the humanities
[Music]